So for this problem imagine you’re a criminal,
specifically a bank robber. And from the bank
you stole three things, a statue, a mask, and
an erne. And I should probably got pictures to
help you visualize this scenario. So now I’ve
added pictures. Believe me you have no idea
how long it took indiscernible and to make
any scenario more realistic we’re going to add
of course monetary and physical attributes to
each of these items. And you want to steal
weighs 15 kilograms and costs $30,000 and
the scary mask weighs 9 kilograms and is worth
$16,000 and lastly we have the erne. The erne
weighs 8 kilograms and costs $15,000. So now
I present to you a question. You didn’t go
to the Jim enough and you can only carry
20 kilograms. So how would you solve this?
One thing you might do, if you’re in a hurry and
you’re about to be chased down by the police
is take the one that weighs the least and try to
get as many things as possible, hoping that you
will make enough money from indiscernible
Another opportunity might be to take the one that
is worth the most, kind of ignoring what it weighs
. Another choice would be to calculate the ratio
between the weight and how much its worth.
That way you chose items as long as you can carry
them based on the cost per kilogram basically, the
amount of money you’re making per weight.
It turns out all three of those solution just
don’t work for this problem. The last one
will work, if you can take say half an erne
, but for this you don’t really want to take
half the erne. It’s worth nothing, unless it’s
sold together and same for the mask and statue
. So, you want to choose specifically which
items to take. So taking the statue along
doesn’t work. And it turns out the correct
answer is to take the mask and the erne.
So this is a surprisingly common problem in
computer science and I suppose if you’re in
a life of crime, it comes up often too. In
computer science and economics this comes up
when dealing with kind of resource obligation
and making choices about which items to chose
based on how much a cost function and how
much they’re worth to you. So this is tricky to
do quickly. And so when I’m going to ask you
to do it, I mean, you can numerate all the
possibilities, but that doesn’t really scale
once you get to say, I don’t know, 15, 20
items. So we’re going to ask you to do is to
write two functions that will help us to check
whether given solution is correct.
The first answer we’re going to write is called
heist valid. And this is going to return true or
false on whether or not the items you’re stealing
is a valid thing to take away. We’re going to
ask if everything you’re trying to steal is less
than the total weight that you can carry and
never going to think about heist total, which
given a list of things you’re going to steal
returns how much all those items are worth
. So heist valid for the mask and the erne,
that’s the correct answer. Nine plus eight
is less than 20, so we’re going to return true
. And the heist total we’re going to add 16 or 15
in return to that total, pretty straightforward.
But we’re going to make it a little bit more
tricky since we know how skilled you’re
and require you to get off a one line solution
. Hence this doesn’t really come off, up often
when you’re in the real world programming
, but we’re enforcing it here so that we
encourage you to use these comprehensions
and kind of think out of out of type the box
. So what are inputs? We’re going to take in
three things. A dictionary that essentially
catalogues all the things that we’re able to
steal. Each key in a dictionary is the name
of the item that we can steal. And the value
is a tuple where the first entry in the tuple
is the weight of the item in kilograms and
the second entry is the monetary value of
the tuple in dollars. Although the units here
don’t really matter as far as we’re consistent
. We also have a limit to what we can carry
. And lastly we have a list of strings
corresponding to the heist here of what we’ve taken.
So let’s do the first function. Since its
we have to return something,
its probably going to start with a return keyword
. So what we’re going to do in this one line is
add up the weight for each item that we’ve
taken and see if its less than the limit. And
because python is so awesome, this is pretty
easy. So we’re going to take the sum of a
list comprehension that generates a list of the
weight of each item that we’ve taken. This is
going to be the name of the item and that’s how
we’re going to get the tuple out of the dictionary
and we just care about the first item and
that dictionary in for takings.
So we’re going to go through each string and the
taken list, look up the value in the dictionary
corresponding to that item and take the first
element in the tuple, which is the weight and
we’re going to return that in our list. So when
take the sum of that and we’re simply going
to check, if it’s less than or equal to the
limit. That’s a one line solution. Hurray!
The next problem is going to have a very similar
answer. In this case, we’re going to go through
each item and take in get the tuple out of the
available dictionary for that item and simply
sum up the cost. Here is the key difference.
So this list comprehension returns a list of all
key values of each item and we’re going to
take the sum of return. Those are
one line solutions to each of those functions.